Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Earlier, we have talked about a few amazing
algorithms to teach digital creatures to walk.
And this time, we're interested in controlling
the joints of a digital character to not only
walk properly, but take into consideration
its surroundings. This new version can navigate
in 3D with static and dynamic, moving obstacles,
or even dribble a ball toward a target. Loving
the execution and the production value of
this paper.
This is accomplished by an efficient system
that consists of two controllers that are
represented by learning algorithms.
One, the low level controller is about about
maintaining balance and proper limb control
by manipulating the joint positions and velocities
appropriately. This controller operates on
a fine time scale, thirty times per second
and is trained via a 4-layer neural network.
Two, the high level controller can accomplish
bigger overarching goals, such as following
a path, or avoiding static and dynamic obstacles.
We don't need to run this so often, therefore
to save resources, this controller operates
on a coarse time scale, only twice each second
and is trained via a deep convolutional neural
network.
It also has support for a a small degree of
transfer learning. Transfer learning means
that after successfully learning to solve
a problem, we don't have to start from scratch
for the next one, but we can reuse some of
that valuable knowledge and get a headstart.
This is a heavily researched area and is likely
going to be one of the major next frontiers
in machine learning research. Now, make no
mistake, it is not like transfer learning
is suddenly to be considered a solved problem
- but in this particular case, it is finally
a possibility. Really cool!
I hope this brief exposé fired you up too.
This paper is a bomb, make sure to have a
look, as always, the link is available in
the video description.
And by the way, with your support on Patreon,
we will soon be able to spend part of our
budget on empowering research projects. How
amazing is that?
The new Two Minute Papers shirts are also
flying off the shelves! Happy to hear you're
enjoying them so much. If you're interested,
hit up http://twominutepapers.com if you're
located in the US. The EU and worldwide store's
link is also available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!